- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here
from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our daily live stream.
This is a way we've started
this a couple of weeks,
actually a months ago now.
As way for all of us
to take connected during times
of social distancing and school closures.
Then it's, we're just having
an interesting conversation.
We have a lot of interesting guests
and today we will just be doing
an ask me anything,
where you can literally ask me anything
for those of y'all on YouTube or Facebook.
Start putting your questions in.
I have team members who
are helping me out surfacing
questions to answer,
and I'm, literally happy
to answer anything.
Before we start,
I want to give a special,
thanks to several corporate partners
who have allowed us to
do what we're doing,
especially with our response to COVID-19,
special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT and T,
Fastly, and Novartis.
We were running a deficit
even before this crisis.
And you can imagine
our server costs have
gone up dramatically.
We're trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs.
So this support has helped a lot,
and special thanks to the many
other foundations and corporations
that have helped us well
beyond before COVID.
But I do like to emphasize that
we are still running in a deficit.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
Every donation makes a difference.
So with that let's,
just jump into asking me anything,
for whatever that's worth.
It looks like there
are some questions that have come in.
So, Jason Dunlap from Facebook asks,
Hey, Mr. Khan member of
Khan Academy since 2011.
So Jason, you've been with us
since near the beginning.
Is there a particular subject matter
with which you struggled?
How did you deal with it?
I think the first time
that I really found myself struggling
with a class.
I was a student
that tended to do really,
I was academically doing
fine most of my career,
but then once I got into high school,
I got really,
I wanted to accelerate even more.
I got very,
I guess you could say
mathematically ambitious.
And I think I was my sophomore year.
I went to the local university
and I started taking classes there.
And the first few classes
I found quite straight,
they didn't cause too much trouble.
But I remember when I took
that first real analysis course,
For those of y'all,
who aren't familiar with real analysis,
that's kind of the first real,
like mathematically math course
where we go really deep into proofs.
You go really deep into the analysis of,
the real number system
and functions and all of that.
And I think that switching gears
from what you typically do
in most of your math,
your high school career of
where you're learning about,
for sure a lot of concepts and procedures,
but you're not as mathematically rigorous.
I guess you could say
real mathematicians are.
That actually did cause
a little bit of like,
I remember there was
a couple of weeks
where I just like,
of course a leads A to B,
why do I have to prove it?
But then once I got over it,
I definitely started really enjoying it.
And that's part of the reason
why I eventually became a math major,
because I saw the beauty
in that kind of real, formal logic.
But that was definitely
a time that I at least,
for a period struggled a bit
there's, let's see if there's other causes
that I really had difficult.
As I went, in my Khan Academy mode,
part of the fun of my job,
is being able to refresh
or learn new subjects
to be able to teach it better.
And, organic chemistry is interesting
because I did take it in college.
And when I took it in college,
I learned it.
I did fine in the course,
but when we were going to
cover it on Khan Academy,
I really wanted
to be able to do it
in a way that was as intuitive
as what we could do in math
or physics or regular chemistry
or any other subject.
And it did take me a little bit of time
to get that intuition
for organic chemistry,
because the way it's typically taught
the way it's typically
surfaced in textbooks,
it just feels like
a bunch of random mechanisms that you,
that a lot of students
just go through a memorize.
But when you really
start to think about it,
there are some very beautiful themes
or concepts that transcend all
of organic chemistry.
It's all about electronegativity,
which atom and a molecule
is the one that really wants
to hug those electrons,
really wants those electrons closer to it.
And from then,
you actually can deduce,
a lot of the mechanisms.
You don't have to memorize them all,
or even if you do memorize some of them,
you can kind of see the intuition
of why the universe does what it does,
because of the electronegativity.
But that was definitely a little bit of,
it took me a little bit of time
to start to see that thread line.
There's other things,
there's definitely parts of biology
where I'm like,
well, why is that lead to that?
And I would start calling up friends
and people who are
professors in the subject.
And then they would say,
well actually that's an
open area of research.
And so I oftentimes said,
why don't they just tell everyone
at the textbook that we don't know
that that's an area of research,
because I actually think that
is more satisfying to know that,
okay, no one actually has the intuition
for exactly why that leads to that.
And by the way,
if you're asking that question,
you're already at the
frontiers of research,
which I think is a pretty cool idea,
but yeah, let's see.
Facebook, Miguel Hernandez asked,
what is your biggest challenge now
as the leader of Khan Academy?
Great question, Miguel.
I think there's a lot of layers to that.
I think, I would say
the overarching question
that sometimes keeps me up at night is,
if Khan Academy from 10 years ago,
so Khan Academy to do,
so Khan Academy served from 10 years ago,
saw Khan Academy today.
He would say,
wow, that thing that started in
this walk-in closet
got much bigger than expected
to see that
we're over 200 folks
employees around the world.
We have translation projects
where across subject and grade
that served from 10 years ago
would have been overjoyed.
We're like, wow,
Khan Academy has kind of
had escape velocity.
It's able to have the impact
that it was just a delusion,
just a dream 10 years ago.
But I think now,
I feel like,
I guess you could say a stress
or an urgency that we don't squander
the opportunity that we have.
It's great that Khan Academy
has a hundred million registered users
and it serves tens of
millions every month,
but there's billions of people
who need to be empowered and,
not just on a superficial level,
but we want to be able
to empower them deeply
across subjects and grades
and create ways for them
to plug into the broader system.
And there's just still
a lot of work to do.
And, even with this COVID crisis,
there's a lot that's
negative about this crisis.
The silver lining is that
there's an open mindedness
to thinking about all things,
but especially education in new ways.
And so I sometimes,
there's a tension between,
this is a marathon at the end of the day.
Like, the world isn't
gonna change overnight,
but there's moments where there's openness
to new solutions
and I'm always thinking about,
well, how can we Khan Academy
really serve people right now,
right when the need is urgent.
So I think that's kind of the high level.
The biggest tension
is how do you balance between moving fast
and being scrappy
and ultra entrepreneurial
with there's a lot of,
Khan Academy has a lot of users now,
you have to bring them along.
We have a large team,
we got to make sure that we're aligned,
that we're all kind of
marching in the same direction,
so that we can use the resources
that folks are donating
to us as well as possible.
I think one double click below that
it's making sure that
we have the resources
to do what we wanna do
and that we can treat it
as a marathon.
That we do have visibility
over not just this year
or the next several years,
but that we have the visibility
to be able to plan
and actually create
what the world needs
and not just follow the latest trend
or whatever seems to
be hot at that moment.
I think that's another thing
that I think a lot about.
And then you double click below that,
and that gets a little bit more
to the tactical level at Khan Academy.
And this is,
every year and every front few months,
we have spirited conversations
about prioritizing.
And that's hard
because when you have
a limited amount of resources
and you thinking about
the scope of what Khan Academy
is trying to do,
there's things that,
we're able to do
and improve on every year.
And then there's things
that are super valuable
that we just don't have the resources.
We just don't have
the capacity to do every year.
And that's always a
little bit heartbreaking
and that's always hard
to kind of thread the
needle on that level.
But when you really think
about all of the dimensions of conduct,
I mean, I have to remind
myself sometimes too,
because I'm sometimes when the mind says,
Oh yeah, it was a thing.
We have the software.
But if you think about,
we're trying to cover,
13 or 14 years grade levels,
we have Khan Academy
kids we're covering now,
not just math,
but we're doing english and language arts,
reading, social-emotional learning,
the sciences, the humanities
we're doing things like test prep
for the SAT for the LSAT.
And we want to explore ways
to work deeper with districts,
give them things like district dashboards,
run efficacy studies and,
each of these things
you can double click on
and have a bunch of things
that you have to figure out
to do right all while
tens of millions of folks
are using the platform.
It can get complex sometimes.
So I think navigating that complexity,
But with that said,
no one should feel sorry for me.
I consider myself incredibly lucky
to work with this team,
to work with all of
the community at Khan Academy,
to work with the hundreds
of thousands of folks
who donated the Khan Academy
to be able to work on what I think is,
kind of the central issue.
Issue of education,
even some of the issues that
we're dealing with in the world right now,
especially in the US right now,
I talked at length about it on Monday.
Education can empower those who
are oppressed and it
can enlighten those who
are oppressors, because I do think
that most people in the world
are good or can be good.
But they've, might've had weird thoughts
or programming or experiences
that maybe make them deviate
from what would otherwise
be their good selves.
And I think education
is the way to really unlock
and enlightened people
and to see the humanity in others
and to give everyone the critical thinking
so that they can help navigate
their own lives in a positive way,
but also participate in a democracy.
And, democracy is just a magical thing,
that's always gonna lead to good
in order for democracy to work,
the people voting
and the people that they're voting in
need to have be educated,
have really strong
critical thinking skills,
be able to see issues
from multiple dimensions,
be able to empathize with folks
who are not like themselves.
And, it's a longterm, it's a marathon.
It doesn't fix everything overnight.
But if in the longterm,
if Khan Academy is able
to reach billions of folks
and really empower them,
I think we can,
make our positive dent
in the universe, so to speak.
Let's see so Tina Lou says,
how many books do you read every year?
I'm not like a,
there's famous people like Bill Gates
who are known to,
kind of speed read,
consume books that is racist.
Personally, I'm not that fast of a reader.
And, I'll say that
just so other non fast
readers feel comfortable
with things that they're not fast.
I have very good comprehension,
but maybe that's a byproduct
because I actually don't read.
I'm probably the slowest reader.
My wife reads faster than me
my mother-in-law reads faster than me.
Probably many of y'all
read faster than me,
but I definitely immerse myself
when I'm in a book
when I'm in a book,
I definitely like,
I'm in it.
Like, I'm in that reality.
And, and that's probably
why I read a little bit slower.
But, it depends,
I probably read
a handful of books a month,
maybe, right now I'm reading "Shantaram",
which is a 900 page book,
and I'm reading maybe 30 minutes a night.
So that's taking me more than
a couple of weeks to get through,
but I'm really enjoying it.
But sometimes there's quick.
Yes, I would say probably
about two or three books a month.
It sounds about right.
Sometimes it's last,
maybe one, sometimes it's
at the high end of that,
but that's about what I do.
So let's see,
we have a question from John Cheryl
from Facebook, any suggestions
to get a 13 year old
boy hooked on reading?
I have ideas.
I'm not, the expert here,
but I could even try
to channel my own 13
year old self because,
it even goes to the last question.
I actually was not a strong reader
when I was in elementary school.
When I was in second grade,
up until second grade,
I was actually in speech therapy.
'Cause I couldn't even
communicate properly.
My sister was in the gifted
and talented program
where they took her out of class.
She was three years older than me.
And when they started
taking me out of class,
I assumed that surely I'm Ferris brother.
I must be in this program as well.
No, it turns out that
no one could understand
what I was saying.
So I remember going to these rooms
where they would just play these tapes
and make me repeat what they were saying.
And, people still didn't understand,
what I was saying.
And so I had gaps in communication.
I couldn't, I wasn't
that strong of a reader.
I actually probably
didn't really read a full,
proper book until I
was near late elementary school
or even in middle school.
So I no one who knew me
when I was eight
or nine years old would've thought
that I would have become
a voracious reader one day
or maybe are probably even surprised
that I would have even
gotten into education.
But in middle school,
I think, there's a lot of great books
that you're exposed to in middle school.
But they do tend to,
or I don't know,
I'm sure things have changed a bit now,
but when I was in middle school,
they did tend to be a little bit more of
the Victorian era classics,
which now as an adult,
I really appreciate it.
I mean, I said one of my favorite books
is Jane Austen's "Pride and Prejudice",
but I think for a middle school boys,
especially some of the
great science fiction works,
not to stereotype or generalize.
'Cause I think a lot of girls,
young girls like to read these as well.
But, when I first read
the Foundation series
and I read that in middle school
when I first read some of
the "Arthur C. Clark",
I read "Dune" in high school,
I always appreciated the Victorian era,
like the way they observe
the nuances of society
and all that,
but also to have this other dimension
of like space opera
and like how epic the universe could be
and our roles in it.
And just think about
reality in different ways.
I think that just gives
you another dimension.
So my advice long winded way of saying,
expose your son to more types of books
and see what he resonates with.
And sometimes, there's this gravity
that doing the very high
minded academic classic stuff.
But I think there's just a beauty
in just getting started reading.
And once you start
immersing yourself in books
and you realize that
it's the best form of virtual reality
and probably the cheapest
form of virtual reality,
then I think you can get your son hooked
and then he'll start exploring things
that might be a little bit out
of his normal comfort zone.
So that's my best guess.
Let's see, there's a Nikhil Guvendor.
Do I enjoy computer science?
And if so,
what's my favorite programming language.
Well, I do, I mean,
I was a computer science major in college
and the reason why I did that,
it was, this was before
it was obvious that computer science
was a very pragmatic field to go into.
It was because I originally went
into college wanting to be a physics major
because I wanted to understand reality
and I still do.
But what was captivating
about computer science is that
it's kind of a world
where you can create a reality
and you can create tools
that can scale arbitrarily to millions
and millions of folks.
And so, that's what got me
into computer science
and obviously to some degree helped
me get Khan Academy going
and kind of those early
prototypes of our platform.
I don't, say I have
a favorite programming language.
I was use a programming languages
as a means to an end.
I not that I have a deep love for Python
over Java over,
few plus plus or whatever else.
For me it's a mean to an end,
which language is a better tool
for what I'm trying to
accomplish, at that.
I've always programmed more
for the sake of trying to create something
that could be useful
or interesting versus kind
of just the programming
for programming sake.
But I can definitely see
how people are attracted to
the beauty of the programming itself.
'Cause there is something very beautiful
about kind of a logical structures.
And I think it does really help
you learn to think critically
and logically regardless
of whether you end up
becoming a programmer or not.
Let's see from YouTube,
Kevin Brazos says, hi Sal,
where would you say your
optimism comes from?
I've always admired that presence in
your live streams and videos.
Also, my background is
middle school science.
I would love to help well, Kevin thanks.
Thanks, (mummurs).
I mean, look I think,
we all have a choice in life.
Things are gonna happen to us for sure.
And I consider myself lucky
that when you look at the whole spectrum
of the things that can
happen to you in life,
I've for the most part avoided
most of the really bad ones knock on wood.
But no matter what happens to you a lot,
depends on how you choose to look at it.
There's the famous cliche,
is glass half full glass, half empty.
And I have found that no
matter what life throws at you,
or at least those in me,
if I take it from a kind of
a more optimistic point of
view it's more productive,
it's more constructive
and it puts positive energy out there.
I've said it in multiple times
on this live stream
for students going to college and saying,
I need to go to this college
or that college,
or I need to go into that career.
I was like,
it's really what you put out there
that comes back regardless of
where you go to college
or what you work in.
If you put positive energy out there,
if you have a sense of curiosity,
if you genuinely care about other people,
then they will generally care about you.
Things will be interesting.
You will get a lot out of the experience.
So I think when that clicks,
there's like, wow,
I should be optimistic.
I'm sure you know, who knows?
I don't know how much of
it is hard wired into folks.
I would say in high school,
in certain circles I
was probably optimistic
and certain places I
was probably a little bit angry.
I was probably a little bit angsty.
I said in the past,
I was the lead singer
of a heavy metal band.
And if I were to see some
of the lyrics that we,
it probably would make,
in fact it would make me cringe today
because we were, I was angry.
I was frustrated
for who knows how much of
it was teenage angst.
How much was it just
context that I was in.
But when I reflect on that,
I realized that it's much,
better to be not as angsty.
It's a better way to approach the world.
And the world kind of tends
to reflect that back when,
you do it.
One piece of advice,
and I do this to myself all the time
is for smile.
For smile, you might say like,
that seems forced,
like literally like smile.
But I actually have read research that,
just as if you're happy,
it makes you naturally smile.
It's almost hard not
to smile if you're happy,
the other way around,
if you force the smile,
that looks a little bit sinister,
that it can actually make you
a little bit happier.
So I've tried that,
everyone who's watching try
to force a smile.
I know there's a lot going on
in the world right now.
That's stressful and should
not make any of us happy.
It doesn't, help you
or the world to be down.
We should always be kind of like,
Hey, look this is the data.
This is what we have to deal with now.
How can we put one foot in front
of the other to make positive change?
I think is always the question we should,
be asking ourselves,
and we have this one life to live.
And so as we try to make
that positive change,
even when we fail,
even when we get knocked down,
how do we live in the moment
and appreciate these moments we have to,
even sometimes fail and
make the most of it.
So, let's see, Elliot H.
Says, Dumbledore Sal.
Well, thank you for calling
that as many of y'all know,
I've always had the secret aspiration
to be a Dumbledore like figure one day.
Did you always have
a Buddhist flesh, Hindu
detached philosophy?
When did you start forcing yourself
to smile and enjoy the process
rather than frown
worrying about the result?
It's interesting. I mean,
a lot of these ideas
are often associated with
Eastern philosophies,
like Buddhist, Hindu, Vedas philosophies.
But if you look
at almost any philosophical system,
even many from the West Stoicism famously,
from the Greeks and the Romans,
it's essentially the same general idea
of not becoming attached to the outcome
and really just doing what is right.
Not only will you be
in some ways a better human being,
but you're also going
to be a happier human being,
a more peaceful human being.
And if you look at some of
the especially the mystical traditions
and some of them,
the major religion,
when you look at the Sufi traditions,
you look at Gnosticism
and Christianity there's definitely
the mystical traditions in Judaism.
They also, kind of go into some
of these same ideas.
In Hebrew, the word sin,
we have this notion that sin is,
when you go against
the laws of the divine laws
or however you want to define it.
But the original meaning
of sin is to miss the point.
And there are interpretations
of many religions where,
notions of evil
are much more about getting sucked,
into the illusion of power
and materiality and,
comparing yourself to others
and, status and
that almost constructs,
not to get too philosophical,
but that almost constructs
a hell of it in its own sort in your mind.
'Cause that obsession,
that anxiety over,
keeping up with others,
comparing to others.
I'm not where I should be.
I wanna be richer.
I wanna be more powerful.
I wanna be better looking.
I wanna have better things.
That missing the point
almost creates a form of a hell,
even in your own mind.
So I think this is actually
a thread that exists
throughout pretty much
any religious tradition
or any philosophical system,
like the Stoics.
I think I kind of personally,
stumbled into this.
I've always been intrigued
by making sense of the universe
that we live in.
I think it was really,
when you were a teenager that you really,
a lot of teenagers out there think that,
okay, people who are 50, 60, 70,
or 80 years old must be
way deeper than I am,
because they've had so much more time
to think about it.
But I think,
it's actually in middle schoolers
and teenagers that
are the ones that
are oftentimes the thinking
the most deeply about some of these.
Like, why do we exist?
Why am I here?
What's the purpose of life?
And then when all this happens,
you go to college,
you get a job,
you have a family.
And you're just like,
okay, I got to pay my mortgage.
I got to make sure my
kids learn how to swim.
I got to have all these social gatherings.
I got to make sure that
I get that promotion.
And so actually I think a lot of adults,
have, almost that muscle
of thinking deeply
about the universe we live in,
and what it means to be a good person,
et cetera, oftentimes atrophies.
So anyway, to answer your question,
probably in middle school,
I was drawn to some of these things
and I continue to be,
and I think now that I'm middle aged,
and I realized that,
the time goes by very fast in life.
It feels like just
yesterday I was in college,
but that's literally 20 years ago.
And another 20 years
I'm going to be in well into my sixties.
And another 20 years of that,
if I'm lucky,
I may or may not be around.
And so I think it is,
a lot of times people think
it's a distraction to think
about these philosophical ideas
or our purpose in life,
or, how we fit into the cosmos or,
the nature of however
you wanna to view it,
God, the universe.
But I don't think it's ever too early
to think about that.
If anything, a lot of the other things
we have in our life is
a distraction from that.
There's, I forgot who said it,
I forgot which philosophical
system it came out of.
But, when you meditate and you still,
your mind, it's much more about,
it's not about forgetting
your kind of problems.
It's more about remembering
what you really are,
that you aren't defined just by your name,
your persona, your gender,
your status in the world,
your education, all of these things
that frankly are egos identify
very strongly with.
But when you really stole your mind,
you realize that you're in awareness
and that's all you really know.
And that when you kind of strip away,
some of those other things,
it can give you peace
and clarity on a lot of levels,
but not just kind of at a spiritual level,
but to engage with the world as a whole.
But anyway, I'll get off
of my soap box on philosophy.
John Corley from Facebook says,
you are aging Sal just like me,
silver Fox, unlike me.
Yes, I guess I am.
I have to say,
all this high-minded talk
about not being having vanity
and not being connected,
not letting your ego run.
There is something that
hit me when I hit 40.
I'm now 43.
You're gonna hit,
be 44 where it was.
It didn't hit my wife as bad.
It hit me
and maybe maybe I do have more vanity
than I'd like to admit,
but it was that realization,
that my wife and I had
been married 16 years.
And when we got married,
we were in their twenties where,
we're young, 16 years kind
of went by super fast.
I think that's a reflection
of my wife being a,
or mama, being a,
a wonderful person to share a life with.
And I'm like,
wait, another 16 years,
I'm going to be 60.
60 is like, I never imagined myself.
(laughs)
And so, yeah, no,
there is something about aging that,
that definitely starts to hit you.
At least hit me when I'm 40.
And and yeah, but we're,
we're all aging,
the beard isn't helping
'cause my beard is grayer than normal,
but I'm resisting any temptations
to use any dyes or anything
to try to be something that I'm not,
but I'm sure those words will come
to bite me back when I show up
on this live stream
with jet black beard in a few weeks.
(laughs)
I see we have maybe a time
for one or two more questions.
Let's see, Attara Lapet
asks from Facebook.
How would I maintain mastery
based learning in university?
What I would say
when you learn things in university,
don't just cram for the test.
Yes. Try to get good grades.
And if you need a cram sometimes,
'cause you kind of let
things slide a little bit,
do that, but always review it
and learn and try to learn for mastery.
And if you do that,
what you're gonna find is,
if you really master
those introductory courses in college,
the rest of the course
actually ended up pretty intuitive.
If you don't master
those introductory courses in college,
the rest of the courses
in college are gonna continue
to be a struggle
and you're gonna continue to have to cram.
And you feel like
you're not really learning anything.
So I would say,
especially those introductory courses
get really deep mastery of them.
And then you'll be pretty unstoppable.
I mean, I know people with PhDs in biology
and they'll tell you,
if you really master
that first year biology course,
you can have a very deep conversation
with them or with your professors
or whoever else.
That's my best advice.
Maybe one more question,
Tina Lou, do you like teaching?
Yeah. I mean, if it's not obvious,
I love it.
I consider myself very fortunate because,
to be able to have the opportunity
to learn material
in the non-stressful way
where I'm not being evaluated,
but I can just learn it
for the sake of learning,
but then have a reason for learning it,
so that I can digested in my own mind
and then help other people
get to the same place.
I think it's a incredibly powerful thing.
And I remember when I was
a kid reading textbooks from,
some great thinkers,
so to speak,
there's a certain connection
that you form across time
and space when you're able
to go really deep
and especially intellectual
or philosophical subjects.
And, I feel very privileged
and very lucky that hopefully,
I can help.
And the Khan Academy team
can help form those same connections
with people that we might
not know across time and space.
There might be some young girl
in the village someplace in 300 years and
hopefully Khan Academy still around
and maybe some of our existing content
is hopefully still useful for her.
And she's just like, Oh, wow.
I feel connection with
these folks back in,
the 21st century.
I think there's just something
really cool about that.
And as I was just saying,
we're in this puzzle called life
and to understand it
and learning new things
is the best way I can think of,
really trying to make
sense of this puzzle,
where in, this universe we're in
and our purpose
in the fairly limited time that we have.
So I'll let everyone go.
I got a little bit more philosophical,
maybe what's going on
in the world is making maybe,
all of us a little bit
more philosophical now.
I pride myself to Khan Academy
where we're we're nonpolitical.
We definitely, I try to keep,
any kind of clear religious
or spiritual beliefs to myself
'cause we're not about condoning one,
one side or anything,
one spiritual viewer and others.
I hope I didn't cross any lines.
But I just want to thank
everyone for joining.
And as always,
I enjoyed this
and, these really stressful times,
obviously you have everything going
on in the US which is,
I'm trying to pick between
the word fortunate or unfortunate.
It's good that finally,
it feels like
there's energy behind making change.
Obviously, the unfortunate thing
is the context that
are forcing folks to,
have to take a lot of action here,
but between that
and obviously what's
going on with COVID-19
and being socially distant.
I know it's a hard time
for a lot, of folks.
So just encourage you yourself.
Don't, take it easy on yourself.
No matter what life stage you are in
and try to enjoy the moment,
give yourself some moments of stillness.
I try to force a smile every now and then,
and hopefully those smiles
become a little bit more
automatic and normal.
And I will see all of y'all on Monday.